the images were captured by satellite
they may not be related to the aircraft
the assessment of these images was
provided by the Australian geospatial
intelligence organization or a Geo
because that's a mouthful as a possible
indication of debris south of the search
area that has been the focus of the
southern search operation since Monday
17th of March the image is in the
vicinity of the search area defined and
searched in the past two days
further images are expected after
commercial satellites were redirected to
take high-resolution images of the areas
of interest these will be provided in
due course for aircraft have been
reoriented to locate the objects
approximately 2,500 kilometers southwest
of Perth as a result of this information
a Royal Australian Air Force Orion
aircraft arrived in the area about 1:50
p.m. this afternoon a further three
aircraft have been tasked by RCC
Australia to the area later today
including a Royal New Zealand Air Force
Orion and the United States Navy
Poseidon aircraft the Poseidon aircraft
should be on scene now the second
Australian Orion departed Royal
Australian Air Force Base Pierce at 2:00
p.m. this afternoon and should be on
scene at 6 p.m. this afternoon the New
Zealand Orion is due to depart at 4 p.m.
this afternoon and should be on scene at
8 p.m. a Royal Australian Air Force
c-130 Hercules aircraft has been tasked
by RCC Australia to drop datum marker
boys these marker boys assist RCC
Australia by providing information about
water movement to assist in drift
modeling they will provide an ongoing
reference point
if the task of relocating the objects
becomes protracted a merchant ship that
responded to a shipping broadcast issued
by our CC Australia on Monday is
expected to arrive in the area about 6
p.m. having been diverted by our CC
Australia the Royal Australian Navy
warship HMS success is enroute to the
area if it is some days away
she is equipped to recover any objects
located and proven to be from mh370 the
focus for AMSA is to continue the search
operation with all available ships and
aircraft the ships and aircraft are
searching for any signs of the missing
aircraft weather conditions are moderate
in the southern Indian Ocean where the
search has taken place however poor
visibility has been reported and this
will hamper both air and satellite
efforts AMSA continues to hold grave
concerns for the passengers and crew on
board and I must emphasize that these
objects may be very difficult to locate
and they may not be related to the
search